[Musique]
vous amène dans le garage
aujourd'hui pour parler des pneus
d'hiver en vous le savez ça devient
obligatoire pour les automobilistes au
québec à partir du 1er décembre c'est
quelqu'un c'est vraiment au début du
mois de décembre que c'est obligatoire à
partir de cette année mais selon c'est à
québec qui collabore avec météomédia ce
serait préférable de ne pas attendre la
dernière minute parce que on le sait les
chutes de neige ça peut arriver bien
avant cette date la halle et gauthier
porte-parole de ces à québec est avec
moi pour en parler bonjour à nîmes où on
sort à peine d'une première semaine que
vous avez appelé la semaine nationale de
prise de rendez vous pour les plus
divers webb à l'idée c'était de marquer
le pas de marquer l'imaginaire des
propriétaires d'automobiles parce que
effectivement la date de obligatoire
pour les plus divers sur les voitures a
été devancé au 1er décembre
alors on perd 1 2 semaines pour procéder
ça paraît pas pareil et donc dans un
contexte de pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
aussi dans l'industrie des ateliers
mécaniques mais ça va occasionner une
certaine pression est donc souvent au
québec on a la mauvaise habitude
d'attendre à la toute dernière minute de
ce débat y ait pas de neige pas de
classe a pas de vérité là donc j'ai pas
besoin d'un énième report annoncé ça et
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle qu'elle ait
passé la première semaine de novembre il
y avait moins 20 il ya eu de la neige
pas si oui c'est vrai et c'est vrai il y
avait beaucoup neigé en novembre mais
vous savez ça fonctionne en tant que
dans mon cas je les prie mon rendez vous
c'est la première fois que je perds mon
rendez vous pour changer mais peut aussi
tôt dans l'année
parce que bon vous l'avez dit aussi
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre ça risque de
mettre beaucoup de pression dans les
garages pas évident l'un aime pas
évident puis on veut que le travail soit
bien fait on veut avoir le rendez-vous
qui nous convient on ne veut surtout pas
se retrouver le 1er décembre pneus
d'hiver parce que les gens courent le
risque de scission pris sur le fait
d'avoir une amende qui peut aller de 200
300 $ plus les frais à ce point la
bouillasse moins bon c'est sûr que ça
peut coûter cher d'avoir une amende
comme celle là mais c'est pas la raison
numéro un non plus pour laquelle on
change le plus divers avancé en raison
de la neige en c'est vraiment une
question de sécurité ou ciation sécurité
routière un peu div
arrêt conçu d'un caoutchouc qui fait
pour garder une souplesse donc une
meilleure adhérence à des températures
fraîches et froide et quand je dis
températures fraîches et froides à
partir de 7 degrés celsius le pneu
d'hiver et le pneu le plus performant
pour assurer une bonne adhérence donc
réduire les risques de dérapage ou
d'accident donc même aujourd'hui même ce
matin on serait mieux d'avoir des plus
de valeur que les pneus d'été voilà oui
déjà des curateurs oui c'est déjà le cas
oui et les gens qui pensent qu en les
ayant trop tôt parce qu a pas de neige
qui a pas de glace et qui aurait pas d
user trop élite alors c'est en fait
c'est un mythe vous ne direz pas trop
vos tenues d'hiver ce qui va user les
pneus d'hiver c'est une température qui
est chaud une température chaude est une
température d'été dont au delà de 20 25
degrés et même si une journée cette
semaine par exemple on annonce des 18 19
degrés dans la grande région de montréal
pour une ou deux journées ça changera
strictement rien à votre univers si vous
voulez des centaines et des centaines de
kilomètres
peut-être mais là vous à l'elysée parce
que vous l'utilisez simplement
ab c'est bon à savoir ça donc c'est le
moment de prendre le rendez vous puis on
peut les changer même cette semaine
c'est déjà fait un mois d'octobre est un
bon moment pour aller changer vous serez
pas dans la cohue ce qui est une bonne
chose qui vous serez prêt quand
malheureusement ou heureusement pour
certains les commerçants ont fermé à la
libre on n'y échappera pas ça c'est sûr
est-ce que la semaine nationale vous
voulez l'installer pour vrai où c'était
vraiment un plus une blague cette année
où une façon ludique de le faire là
c'est une façon ludique de la femme ait
l'intention c'est de la ramener à chaque
année pour que les
les consommateurs les propriétaires
automobile propriétaires de véhicules de
promenade y pense
vous n'êtes pas nécessairement obligé de
faire poser vos pneus la semaine
prochaine mais prenez votre rendez-vous
minimalement pensez-y si vous êtes
envoie un automobiliste qui voyage d'une
région à l'autre
pensez à le faire plus tôt aussi parce
qu'on sait dans les saunas l'hiver peut
arriver très rapidement
déjà on annonce peut-être des petites
chutes de neige en décembre au québec
donc c'est pas assez peu banal et donc
en les faisant tantôt on s'assure
d'avoir le bon rendez vous peut être
bien chaussé donc voulu entrer dans nos
habitudes de pensée à 7 dès le début du
mois d'octobre
en terminant d'avoir devancé son 1er
décembre c'est une bonne chose
passez une bonne chose dans la mesure où
les gens seront prêts plus rapidement on
sait que certains attendaient évidemment
comme le dit trop à la dernière minute
et s'exposer à des risques accrus
d'accident ou d'érable négocier c'est à
québec
merci d'avoir été là ce matin a plutôt
en plus merci bien que prévu